i'm not entirely sure what it looks like
seems pretty clear what it means or what
the consequences are
or not boris johnson today hoping to
turn over a new leaf even as mps demand
yet another investigation into the money
trail behind his flat refurbishment
a day after the electoral commission
said offenses may have been committed
the prime minister sticking to his guns
we will
comply with whatever uh they want and i
don't think there's anything to
uh to see here or to uh to worry about
but what we are doing is focusing
on the stuff that really matters it will
be
for voters to decide what matters and
only after
all the facts surface this man the pm's
new advisor on ministerial interests
is most likely to get to the bottom of
it all but will we ever find out what he
discovers
you have appointed the queen's former
private secretary christopher geit
to look into what happened about the
refurbishment of your flat
could you commit to publishing in full
what he finds and doing uh undertaking
any recommendations uh
that he makes immediately that he makes
them well i'm sure he'll do an
outstanding job
i think what people are focused on
overwhelmingly
is not that kind of uh issue but on
what we're doing to take this country
through the pandemic that's their
argument that the public don't care
well it'll be up to voters to determine
that next week and at subsequent
elections
but there are some conservatives who are
worried some on the conservative party
board which meets in the headquarters
behind me
point out they weren't told that the pm
was being lent
big sums by the party while other tories
worry the sheer
number of investigations into the
conduct of boris johnson
means there's a chance that just one of
them could throw up a big political
headache
boris johnson finds himself at the
center of various investigations that
look at his personal conduct
one concerned his recently confirmed
affair with jennifer arcuri during his
time as london mayor
another is his holiday to the island of
mystique in december 2019 led by the
parliamentary commissioner for standards
and finally the flat refurb and there
there are three investigations into this
headed by different organizations
his mps want there to be a fourth
investigation by the commons watchdog
the labour leader in manchester today
says one of the many
inquiries needs to close the knowledge
gap
we've referred um the prime minister any
number of
inquiries and our job is obviously to
hold him to account in parliament
the first question is who actually paid
for this redecoration in the first place
the second question i think is probably
the bigger question now is why is the
prime minister not prepared to just
answer that question
what is he hiding one man's sleaze
scandal is another man's photo
opportunity here's kiss dahmer and john
lewis making the most of claims the
number 11 flat was upgraded
to banish his predecessor's furnishing
nightmare
gambling that there's political credit
to be had from highlighting the contrast
with a man whose soft finishings and
wallpaper
comes from this shop sam coat sky news